everyone on board a stranded cruise ship
including many Americans are safe after
a terrifying voyage off the coast of
Norway the Viking Skye was carrying just
over 1,300 passengers and crew when it
sent a distress signal Saturday the
vessel had lost power and started
drifting towards land while rocking
violently the heavily listing ship
became stranded in a notoriously rough
stretch of water in the Norwegian Sea
Roxana Saberi is following the ordeal
from London Roxana good morning good
morning
rescuers were forced to airlift 479
passengers many of them elderly from the
stranded ship after it reported its
engines had failed less than a mile from
Norway's rugged coast inside the Viking
sky on Saturday passengers dodged
furniture flying across the floor and
panels falling from the ceiling outside
heavy winds and 26 foot high waves
whipped the luxury cruise ship which
lost power for reasons still unclear has
the ship seesawed icy waters gushed
across the floor terrifying passengers
like Rodney Horgan of Minnesota and I
thought this was it at that time I mean
that's the water is gonna rush in and
and and this is it at risk of crashing
onto the nearby rocky coast of Norway
the ship dropped anchor and started to
evacuate for the next several hours
Norwegian rescue helicopters airlifted
more than half of the roughly 900
passengers to safety including susan and
alan dull burn I'm 71 he's 74 well we
can they took us up together and we got
hooked in and lifted up that was quite a
jolt as the Seas calmed yesterday and
the ship restarted three of its four
engines tugboats towed the Viking sky
back to shore
the Red Cross says several passengers
suffered cuts and broken bones many are
also traumatized the ship was supposed
to arrive here in England tomorrow the
chairman of Viking cruises told local
news media that the passengers many of
them from the US
England and Canada will be compensated
and invited back
bianna not sure how many will be coming
back what a frightening weekend it was
for them we're glad they're all okay
Roxanna thank you